what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and if you're excited
for thor love and thunder i'm about to
tell you some news that is going to make
you even more excited as they have shown
some test screenings for thor love and
thunder and according to these test
screenings christian bale as gore the
god butcher is marvel's best villain
ever then we have the rest of the cast
praising christian bale asgore and
russell crowe as zeus and apparently
he's going to be playing kind of a
different role than we've ever really
seen him play before which apparently
made for an even better performance we
also have some new info about jane
foster's the mighty thor which we'll
dive into as well so let's talk about
all of this praise for thor love and
thunder and thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video we'll get to them
in a bit so for those of you who may not
be aware of this marvel and disney and
other studios as well do test screenings
in advance before the movies come out to
kind of gauge the reaction that the
movie gets from the audience this is a
really great thing because it lets the
studio know if some parts aren't that
well received or if some parts were say
confusing or if just the movie overall
is a disaster for example they did these
test screenings for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness and from what
i heard the test audience was kind of
confused about it all and this led to
reshoots and these reshoots supposedly
made doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness a better movie and less
confusing so these test screenings are
really great and they really help movies
a lot and apparently the feedback for
thor love and thunder is pretty dang
good specifically revolving around
christian bale as the villain fans were
super excited that christian bale was
announced as the villain for thor love
and thunder and even more excited when
we found out that he was going to be
playing gore the god butcher and if you
bring such a big actor into the mcu like
christian bell you better hope that he
delivers and apparently he did it's also
looking like his story is going to be
pretty deep and pretty complex and we're
going to actually sympathize with him as
a villain a lot let's hear what the cast
had to say about christian bale in this
recent interview with fandango what does
christian bring into the thor universe
uh exactly what you'd want hope and
expect uh
nuance complexity
depth um
sort of quirkiness to it which which i
didn't see on the page
um
and
with any sort of classic villain the
fact that you
you find yourself empathizing or or
asking questions that they're asking or
the ideas that they're posing it's not
just stock standards sort of evil yeah
you like root for them sometimes yeah
just great if you're playing the hero
for the villain so
i'd say he's the most uh
sympathetic villain i've had um he's
also tested the highest out of any
villain that marvel's had so that's an
extremely huge statement that
taikawatiti just said right there when
he said he's also tested the highest out
of any villain that marvel's had that's
a huge statement because we've had
thanos we've had loki we've had red
skull we've had all of these major
iconic villains in the mcu with great
performances from the actors that played
them but when tyka is talking about he
tested highest he's talking about that
test audience reaction and there could
have been a few different times that
they've showed this to different
audiences but whatever the situations
were according to marvel studios's tests
christian bale is the highest ranking
villain that marvel's had right now now
chris hemsworth and taiko with tt say
that you can empathize and sympathize
with christian bale's gore the god but
your villain and this is because if you
know the comic book origin of gore the
god butcher his whole entire family dies
in the comics he has a wife and a bunch
of sons and slowly they all start to die
his wife dies and then he only has one
son left where he begs the gods to help
him to spare his son because he is
desperately sick but his son dies so he
believes that there are no gods because
if there were why didn't they help him
and his family now because of this
thinking he gets exiled from his
community and as he's wandering the
desert to die he sees two gods fighting
in the air they fall to the ground and
he walks up to them and he cannot
believe his eyes that the gods are real
the necro sword presents itself to him
and he kills one of the gods then he
sets out to seek revenge on the gods
because they are in fact real but did
not help him as weird as it sounds you
can actually sympathize with that story
he was begging for help to save his last
son after all of his family including
his wife had died that's super sad then
he finds out that the gods were real but
didn't help him so he gets pissed and he
decides that the gods are kind of
useless and sets out to kill them all
now amongst christian bale being in thor
love and thunder we also have natalie
portman returning and russell crowe
making his mcu debut as zeus and the
cast just praises him and we'll get to
that in just a bit but first thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
there's a lot going on in the world
right now and things can get pretty
stressful and pretty overwhelming and
that's why better help is such a great
platform if you need somebody to talk to
or you just need to check up on your
mental health better help allows you to
do just that you can connect to and talk
to a therapist right from your phone and
they have a very broad range of
officially licensed therapists over 20
000 therapists in their network so this
makes it to where you can really find
that therapist who is right for you and
if you go with a therapist and decide to
change you can do that for free since
the pandemic it's been a lot easier to
do things and meet with people from the
comfort of your home and better help
allows you to do that and it's not just
therapy sessions you can message your
therapist at any time head to
betterhelp.com cosmic wonder to answer
some questions and get paired with a
therapist within 48 hours you'll also
get 10 off your first month by clicking
the link in the description down below
that's betterhelphelp.com
cosmic wonder now as far as zeus is
concerned here's what chris hemsworth
had to say about russell crowe's
performance i never thought i'd see the
day where russell would appear on screen
with hints at gladiator imagery yet with
a wink totally self-deprecating he
didn't hold back i'm such a fan i've
been since i first started acting
there's such a weight and a seriousness
to his performance and to him as an
individual from afar but meeting him he
has a great sense of humor and did
whatever taika asked on set which was
mind-blowing and it was really fun to
play with the mythology going from norse
to greek mythology taika pulls all these
worlds together then natalie portman
said about russell crowe it was so much
fun to see russell crowe play zeus and
have such a great sense of humor with
the character it was fun to see him be
silly i think we're so used to him in
these very strong heroic roles so it was
fun to see him be able to let loose so
according to chris hemsworth russell
crowe is mind-blowing in this role and
according to natalie portman he's also
kind of silly this is pretty different
than what we're used to seeing russell
crowe play as far as movie roles go he
typically plays very serious roles like
in gladiator but this is going to be a
sort of silly movie just like thor
ragnarok thor ragnarok was amazing but
it was kind of silly which was awesome
and we've already seen the silliness be
shown in the trailers where zeus flicks
thor and accidentally knocks off all of
his clothes russell crowe an amazing
actor being silly when we've never
really seen that from him before just
adds to the awesomeness of thor love and
thunder so so far it's said that
christian bale is amazing as gore
russell crowe is fantastic as zeus and
taiko with tt has recently offered us a
little glimpse of what natalie portman's
jane foster the mighty thor is going to
be like he recently shared that he had
to kind of convince natalie portman to
come back and he did that by convincing
her that they're actually going to
change jane foster from the first two
movies and have her be kind of different
or really different in thor love and
thunder and what's funny is he actually
kind of critiqued the old jane foster
from the first two films here's what
taika watiti had to say about convincing
natalie portman to come back and thor
love and thunder as jane foster i went
to her house and she gave me a glass of
water i think that what we did with
ragnarok was it made these movies
appealing to other actors as well like
christian bale really he saw that and he
was like i want to do something fun and
came here wanted to be a part of this
thing and natalie too and i think that
she was just wanting to make sure that i
don't even know how to say this but her
character in those first few films it's
probably not the most exciting version
of the female character that we want
from these films i had to just talk to
her about the fact that i wanted to
change that character just like we
changed thor's character for ragnarok
and to give her a bit more license to be
adventurous and fun because natalie's a
really funny person and sometimes those
sort of things cannot i don't know
they're not the main focus when they
come up with characters and you know in
films so taika says that they pretty
much had to change jane foster's
character for thor love and thunder
which is a great thing because again the
first two films aren't received that
very well from the fandom but there
certainly is a lot more that they could
have done with the character and it's
good to know that taiko ati is doing
that with jane foster and thor love and
thunder so expect jane to be really
really awesome but also at the same time
expect her to be silly and funny much
like the vibes in thor ragnarok it looks
like a lot of the humor is going to be
coming from obviously the main cast but
also from zeus and jane foster and then
we get the seriousness from christian
bale's gore the god butcher but with
these raving reviews and praise of these
actors and their roles i am even more
excited to watch thor love and thunder
now and it's less than one month away so
let me know how excited you are to watch
it in the comments down below please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof